[موسيقى]
انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياض وهذه اخبار الساعه
في ايران وزير الخارجيه يستفزوا المحتاجين
بحديثه عن ديمقراطيه ايرانيه قويه
والمتظاهرون مستمرون
السودان يستعد لمرحله جديده من الحكم
المدني غدا يتوج بتوقيع اتفاق بين الجيش
والمدني
فرنسا تعبر الى ربع النهائي على حساب
البولندا وانجلترا تبحث عن مكان وصله
ثمانيه الكبار
والسنغال تبحث عن مفاجاه نهايه الشوط
الاول باثنين مقابل صفر لصالح
[موسيقى]
وسيتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
في اول انتصار معلن للمحتاجين في ايران
شرطه الاخلاق او ما تعرفوا بشرطه القمع
تحل بقرار رسمي من النظام مقتل الشابه
الكرديه مساء ميني على ايديهم جعلت هذا
الجهاز ضمن بنك اهداف المحتجين منذ اليوم
الاول للاحتجاجات من مدينه قم ذات الرمزيه
الدينيه لدى الايرانيين انها المدعي العام
الايراني محمد جعفر منتظر مهام شرطه
الاخلاق البرلمان والسلطه القضائيه في
ايران بصدد مراجعه قانون الزاميه الحجاب
وان النتائج ستظهر في غضون اسبوع او
اسبوعين الجهاز موجود منذ ثمانيات القرن
الماضي وكان يتابع ادق تفاصيل النساء عبر
دوريات شبيهه بدوريات التوجيه قبل ان تاخذ
شكلها الجديد تحت اسم ارشاد اي شرطه
الاخلاق في 2005 من رجال بزين اخضر ونساء
يرتدين زيا اسود وفي عام 9283 قرر
البرلمان الايراني فرض عقوبه الجلد اربع
74 جلده على ما اسماه بالصور ثم اضيفت
اليها مؤخرا عقوبه السجن بشهرين وفي عام
96 نفذت وزاره الداخليه الايرانيه مشروعا
اطلق عليه محاربه الحجاب السيء وبدا في
العاصمه طهران واستمرت هذه الدوريات في
نشاطها بعد ذلك التاريخ مع تغييره في
الشكل ومسميات ثم اخذ قسم شرطه الاداب في
اواخر ايام الرئيس الاصلي محمد خاتم
[موسيقى]
اصلي ثابت
اي لقطه
[موسيقى]
ويبدو ان قرار احلي شرطه الاخلاق لن يخمد
نار الاحتجاجات في ايران حيث تستمر موجه
الدعوات للمشاركه الواسعه في تظاهره
حتى السابع من الشهر الجاري تحت شعار
انتفاضه ديسمبر
الرئيس ابراهيم الرئيسي كلمه امام الطلاب
في جامعه طهران الاربعاء المقبل هذا وجدد
وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين امير عبدالله
المتعلقه بالمفاوضه النوويه مؤكدا ان
الدول الغربيه تستغل الاحداث الاخيره في
بلاده وان الولايات المتحده
والحريه في ايران تسير بشكل جيد
[موسيقى]
احد دوافع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هو
اجبار ايران على تقديم تنازلات كبيره
لصالحها على طاوله المفاوضات تاكدوا ان
الاطار الديمقراطيه والحريه في ايران يسير
على ما يرام
كشفت مصادر مطلعه للعربيه
الى النساء اللواتي لا يرتدين الحجاب بشكل
الذي يفرضه النظام منذ عقود فيما قال
ناشدونا وحقوقيون ان الاحتجاجات المستعمله
في البلاد منذ اكثر من شهرين اجبرت النظام
الايرانيه على التراجع الجانبه المدعي
العام محمد جعفر منتظر لان البرلمان
والسلطه القضائيه يعملون على مراجعه قانون
الحجاب وان النتائج ستصدر في غضون اسبوع
او اسبوع
كاي فتاه شابه تغني وترقص تحلم وتنتظر ليس
الموت طبعا موت امين على يد شرطه الاخلاق
في ايران كان بدايه نهايه الدوريات
القمعيه التي ارتكبت انتهاكات عديده بحق
النساء
وارتفعت شعارات غير مسبوقه رافضه للنظام
القمعي والانتهاكات ضد الشعب عموما
والنساء خصوصا
ومع الشعارات تنوعت اساليب الاحتجاج
اضرابات وحملات على وسائل التواصل
واعتصامات لم يوفر المحتجون وسيله لاسماع
صوتهم
كذلك تعددت اساليب القمر
جمهوريه المرشد انها ليست غريبه عن حراس
الجمهوريه
[موسيقى]
الناشطون والناشطات املو ان تكون مهما امي
اخر المنضمين الى قوافل الموت لكن
الانتفاضه حملت معها ايضا وجوه جديده
والشابه
نقا شكارني 16 عاما انتهت حياتها على يد
الحارس الثوري
[تصفيق]
لكن مقابل كل هراوه صرخه بشعارات كبيره
واحلام اكبر لم يعد الامن مطلوبا بل سطر
المحتجون مذكره اعتقال بحق المرشد
والجمهوريه مع دخول الانتفاضه شهرها
الثالث
ودماء كثيره تراجعت الجمهوريه امام
الانتفاضه المدعي العام يحل شرطه الاخلاق
رئيسي يجتهد في تفسير الدستور وبين الرئيس
والمدعي العام نشيطه تقول ان المحتاجين لم
يخرجوا عز لا امام الرصاص لمجرد اسقاط
شرطه الاخلاق
هذا هو تحدثت صحيفه عن ان شركه استخبارات
الكترونيه اسرائيليه كشفت عن قيام معارضين
ايرانيين بتسريب معلومات شخصيه لعناصر
امنيه من افراد الحرس الثوري والقوات
البسيج والشرطه الذين يتصدون للاحتجاجات
الاخيره في البلاد
وقالت شركه ديب بويدا الاسرائيليه ان
المعارضين النشروا عناوين وارقامه هواتف
العناصر الامنيه على شبكه الانترنت غير
المرئيه دارتنيت لتمكين المواطنين من
الانتقام من افراد هذه الاجهزه التي تقنع
المتظاهرين منذ سبتمبر الماضي
هذا وافدت مصادر مطلعتنا ان القوات
الامنيه القت القبض على احد محرري النشره
السريه لوكاله انباء فارت القريبه من
الحرس الثوري الايراني ويدعى عباس درويش
بعد اختراقه موقع الوكاله من قبل مجموعه
قراصنه اعلنت في بيان الولوج الى النشرات
السريه المرسله الى مكتب المرشد للاعلى
والحرس الثوري والتي تشمل جميع المكالمات
المسجله والمعلومات عن المحادثات الاداريه
والاخبار والاشره معلومات الحساسه عن
المرشد الاعلى والمؤسسات الاستخباراتيه
والامنيه
معنى من لندن الباحث في شان الايرانيه
عارف نصر استاذ عارف اهلا بك معنا لماذا
هناك دعوات جديده للتظاهر رغم اعلان
النظام الايرانيه عن حل شرطه الاخلاق
تحيه طيبه لك يا استاذ صهيب والمشاهديه
العربيه الكرام الواقع انا اعتقد بان لان
نحن امام حراك ثوري وليس ربما احتجاجات
مطلبيه همم محدوده بقضيه شرطه الاداب هذا
فضلا بان لا يزال قضيه حتى حل شرطه الاداب
غير محسوما حتى الان ونحن نعلم بان المدعي
العام لا يستطيع دستوريا وقانونيا ان يحل
شرطه الاهداب لان غرارها يعود الى المجلس
الاعلى للثوره الثقافيه
نفس
الحقيقه ايرانيون شككوا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ان يكون هناك حل لشرطه الاخلاق
يعني ولكن هل تعتقد انه يمكن ان يغامر
النظام ويعلن هكذا اعلان انه منتظر يعني
هكذا اعلان دون ان يكون متاكدا
نعم قد يكون انا اعتقد بان هنالك عده
سيناريوهات منها ربما من خلال هذا الاعلان
اراد النظام الايراني ان يجث النبض يجس
نبض الشارع وكيفيه التجاوب مع هذه الخطوه
وبالتالي سيقدم عليها لان النظام الايراني
براي بانه يحتاج الى ان يخدم عليها لان
هنالك عده امور يبحث عنها منها منها
من خلال حل شرطه الاداب يستطيع تبرعت همم
المرشد الايراني ونحن نعلم بان هنالك لجنه
تغصي حقائق الدوليه بالتالي اذا ما حلت
هذه الامر سربما السهام التي تصيب المرشد
الايراني ستكون اقل النقطه الثانيه هنعتقد
بان هذا الامر يشير بصوره واضحه بان هنالك
عمليه تملص من همم المسؤوليه في اركان
الدوله الايرانيه القضاء يريد ان يتملص
والحكومه وكذلك البرلمان هذه النقطه ايضا
ناتجه من ان النظام الذي اعت على ثنائيه
الاصلاح والاصول و ورمي التهم الان عندما
اصبح نظاما ولائيا اصبح بمشكله لا يستطيع
ان يحل يحل يحلها اذا ما اذا ما سقط
بمثلها كما نشهد
العالمي مباشره من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تحديد سعر النفط الروسيه اتفاق توصلت اليه
دول الاتحاد الاوروبيه 27 مجموعه السبعه
واستراليا رفقه رفض روسي وعدم رضا
اوكرانيا
الروسيه يبلغ 60 دولارا للبرميل الواحد
وابرم الاتفاق بعد ان كان معلقا من قبل
بولندا التي اعترف الضوء الاخضر لهذه
الخطه وينتظر بدء تطبيقه غدا امر رئيس
الاوكراني
يعجبه الرقم المتفق عليه واعتبر انه لا
يعكس جديه تقدم الهدف المرجو لاضعف موسكو
في المقابله الموقف الروسي بدا واضحا منذ
اللحظه الاولى لقرار تحديد سقف لسعر نفطها
فالمتحدث باسم الكريم
سقفا لسعر النقد الروسي وان موسكو لن تزود
الدول التي ستطبق هذا القرار الاوروبي
بدوره اكد نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
ان روسيا لن تتعامل بموجب سقف اسعار النفط
حتى اذا اضطرت الى حفظ الانتاج سفير روسيا
لدى المنظمات الدوليه في الجنه
قال بالفم الملان انه اعتبارا من العام
الجاري ستعيش اوروبا بدون النفط الروسيه
اما تحالفوا اوف كلاس فابقى رسميا على
سياسه انتاج النفط دون تغيير ففي نهايه
اجتماع اليوم اعاد تحالف اوبك بلس
التاكيده على قراراته السابقه بما في ذلك
تعديل وتيره الاجتماعات الشهريه للجنه
الوزاريه المشتركه لمراقبه الانتاج لتكون
كل شهرين مع منح اللجنه صلاحيه عقد
اجتماعات اضافيه او طلب عقد اجتماعي
الوزاري للدول الاعضاء في اي وقت للتعامل
مع اي تطورات في السوق البيان ذكر انه تم
تكرار التاكيد على اهميه الالتزام التام
بالاتفاق واليه التعويض والاستفاده من
فتره التمديد المعتمده في الاجتماع
ونتابع من اثينا معنا من هناك الدكتور عبد
اللطيف درويش استاذ الاقتصاد واداره
الازمات في جامعه كارديف دكتور عبد اللطيف
اهلا بك معنا
روسيا قالت انها لن تبيع نفط خاضعا لصقف
الاسعار حتى لو اضطرت الى تخفيض انتاجها
يجعلنا هذا نتساءل هل سيطبق القرار
الاوروبي بتسقيف سعر النفط الروسي
انا اشك ايضا كما هو لم ينجح الاوروبيين
في مقاطعه بالبدايه قالوا انهم سيقطعون
تماما التعامل مع روسيا في موضوع الغاز
والنفط وامور اخرى ولكنهم لم ينجح هو الان
يضعون سقف وليست في المحاوله الاولى التي
تجري المحاوله من معسكر الغربي او
الاوروبي اعتقد انه لن ينجحون الان روسيا
اعدت 100 سفينه ناقله للبترول ستستخدمها
لارسال بترولها لمن يعني يرغب اعتقد انا
الاسواق الاسيويه بحاجه الى البترول
الروسي وما قامت كما قام الاوروبيين في
البدايه ايضا بالشراء دفتر الروسي بطرق
ملتويه عن طريق تركيا او عن طريق
السفن في افريقيا وما شابه ذلك
الدكتور عبد اللطيف
يعني كيف همم ترى هذا التشكيكه الاوكراني
في جديه القرار الاوروبي كذلك
حق
انا وعلاء انه ايضا الرقم ليس اتصور
بولندا كانت تاخذ نفط ارخص الروسي ارخص من
هذا السعر يعني 60$ 60$ وهذا يعني احد
الاسباب احتجاجه على هذا الموضوع فاعتقد
ان حتى عمليه عدم استجابه الاوبك وايضا
ضغط على الاوبك بطريقه ما اعتقد انه كل ما
ممكن ان يخلقه هذا الموضوع هي عمليه بلبله
في الاسواق العالميه لا اكثر صحيح اعتقد
ان الاوروبيين لن يتحملوا همم يعني تبيعات
هذا القرار كما لم يتحملوا تبيعات
القرارات السابقه نعم ولكن الدكتور عبد
اللطيف يعني هو في النهايه قررت اخذ اذا
ما طبق هذا القرار كيف ترى انعكاسه او كيف
بدات انعكاساته الان على اسعار النفط
يعني اكيد هو اا سيخلق عمليه ضغط على
اسعار النفط لان اسعار النفط شكل انعام هي
اعلى من ذلك يعني في اسواق النفط سيخلق
عمال الضغط وبلبله ولكن عدم اذا لم تخضع
روسيا لهذا لهذا الامر فيسكون سترتفع
اسعار تعلي قررت روسيا للاحجام عن تصدير
النفط لهذه الدول او بيعه باسعار اقل
فمعنى انخفاض كميات النفط في الاسواره في
الاسواق الدوليه يعني ارتفاع النفط وهذا
عكس ما يريده الغرب معنا سيكون له
التابعات على الخزينه الاوروبيه التي ايضا
يعني سيكون هناك في المعروض دكتور باختصار
متى توقعاتك لاي سقف يمكن ان يصل سعر
النفط في حالنا اذا طبق هذا القرار
الاوروبي والتزمت به الدول الاوروبيه حقا
اذا التزموا الاوروبيين وانا اشك في ذلك
انه يلتزمون من خلال شركات اخرى سوف يتم
بالبترول اذا التزم فاعتقد ان اسعار النفط
سترتفع الانسانخفض كميات النفط الروسيه
يعجبون عن تصدير النفط بالتالي سترتفع عن
اكثر من 100 دولار ولكن انا
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور عبد اللطيف
درويش استاذ الاقتصاد واداره الازمات
بجامعه كارديف حدثتنا من الثناء
[موسيقى]
اكيد المستشار الالمانيه
ستواصل والحلفاء تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
التي تحتاجها حتى يوقف بوتين الحرب ويسحب
قوته من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بالاسلحه التي تحتاجها لصدي هجمات روسيا
حتى يوقف بوتين هذه الحرب ويسحب قوته
املوا ان تنتهي هذه الحرب والعدوانيه في
وقت قريب لا نعرف متى لكنها ستنتهي وهناك
شيء واضح ستفشل مهمه ثبوت الروسيه وهي قد
فشلت بالفعل
ميدان الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه يقف على
جانبيه طرف الصراع واختبار فصل الشتاء لم
يحسن بعد ومع دخول النساء
شرقيه اوكرانيا فيما يعيد كل جانب حسابات
اعاده التجهيز العسكري وشحن الامداد
وتنظيم تحركاته العسكريه
صوره تعكس طول امد الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وان لم تغيب عنها مشاهد
الاستضافات المتبادله على مناطق السيطره
العسكريه روسيا تواصل قصف البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه دون هواده اما اوكرانيا
لتحقيق مزيد من التقدم الميداني في ظل
تراجع روسي على الارض
[تصفيق]
تراجع وكبه رصد من قبل الغرب الدائم
لاوكرانيا وسيناريوهات تطرح حول مستقبل
النزاع من قبل قاده عسكريين واستخباراتين
على راسهم اذرلهنز مديره الاستخبارات
الوطنيه
اكثر في ما يخص الاوكرانيين ضمن الاطار
الزمني الحالي
تفاؤل امريكي لصمود القوات الاوكرانيه
التي يحظى بعد عناصرها بدعم وتدريب من قبل
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وبيان اخير لها
يؤكد تراجع التايد الشعبي للحرب الروسيه
اظهر مسح الرسميه
فقط من الروس يريدون استمرار الحرب قد
يواجه الكريم لينس صعوبه متزايده في
الحفاظ على موافقه الشعب على الحرب
توقعات غربيه قبل تعكس عناد التخطيط
العسكري الروسيه حيث اظهرت صور عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه قاعده للجيش الروسي بنيت
في مدينه ماريبول الساحليه التي تؤمن ممر
بريا بين القرمباس وتعطي سيطره على الساحل
الاوكراني المطل على البحر الاسود على
السمان العربيه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه السودان يستعد
لمرحله جديده من الحكم المدني غدا بتوقيع
اتفاق بين الجيش والمدنيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد
وفي وقت سابقا من اليوم نقلت شبكه رضى
الاعلاميه الكرديه على المسؤولين في محور
قوات البيشمركه في شرق دجله سيرفس بابيري
قوله ان ثمانيه صواريخ من نوع كافيوشا
اجتهدفه القاعده وافادت وسائل الاعلاميه
العراقيه بسماع يدويا انفجارات على اطراف
في مدينه الموصل ايضا عاصمه
[موسيقى]
تذهب الى السودان
للتوقيع على الاتفاق الايطاليه بين قاده
الجيش وقوى الحريه والتغيير وستندم
للتوقيع احزاب سياسيه من خارج الحريه
وتغيير لكن
ها تتحول الى نظام مدنيه ديمقراطي فيما
تتخلفه عن التوقيع بعض الحركات المصلحه
اهمها حركه العدل والمساواه بدعمه وزير
الماليه الحاليه جبريل ابراهيم وحركه
التحرير السودان بقياده حكم اقليم دارفور
منياوي
ازمه سياسيه تجاوزت العام خلفها تولي
الجيش او خلفها تولي الجيش السلطه في
الخامس 25 اكتوبر العام الماضي واعلان
حاله الطوارئ وحل الحكومه واعتقال بعض
القيادات السياسيه كما يمهل الاتفاق
الايطالي لتشكيل حكومه المدنيه جديده من
كفاءات مستقله تدير الفتره الانتقاليه
البالغه 24 شهرا بدءا من توقيع الاتفاق
وتنتهي باقامه الانتخابات للتحول الى نظام
ديمقراطيه برلمانيه
[موسيقى]
متابع من الخرطوم مع المحلل والكاتب
السياسيه عمار عوض استاذ عمار اهلا بكم
معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه هل
تلمسون حقيقه اي مؤشرات على ان يكون
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يستعد السودا
لتوقيعه غدا ان يكون هو فعلا حقا
مخرجا للازمه السياسيه
نعم يمكن ان يكون الاتفاق الذي سيوقع غدا
ااا مخرجا اييي لهذه البلاد لانه وضع قطر
اساسيه وعناوين بارزه في ما يتعلق به شكل
الحكم والحياه
الحكم
وان يكون راس الدوله
مدني وان يكون وان يكون لها قضايا طالب
بها الشارع وان يجرا اصلاحات همم وغيرها
لكن همم التحدي الاساسي في نقطتين التحدي
الاول ها هو كيف يمكن للذين سيوقعوا
الاتفاق غدا في توسيع همم دائره همم الذين
همم سينما دعانا نقول لهذا الاتفاق نسبه
لانه هنالك قوه اساسيه غريبه من قوه
الثوره اذا كان ممثله في حزب البعثه او
اذا كان في الحزب الشيوعي وخاصه الحزب
البعثه لاخر لحظه كان موجود في حاله في
الحريه والتغيير المركزي همم ايضا هنالك
قوى السلام كمناوي وجبريل كما تفضلتم انتم
اذا قلنا بالنسبه للاتحاد اذا تمت لملمت
همم هذه القضايا وتم توقيع يمكن همم هم
غريبون يمكن ان يفتح الباب لمناقشه حقيقيه
همم لقضايا الاعتصاديه يعني اضافه الى
الغائبين همم من القوى السياسيه عن همم
يعني الاتفاق الاطار المزمع غدا عذرا على
المقاطعه همم كما يقال الشيطان يكمن في
التفاصيل ومن التفاصيل التي لم يتفق عليها
في هذا الاتفاق الايطالي كذلك قضايا حساسه
منها العداله في المرحله الانتقاليه
واصلاح قطع الامن همم يعني همم هل يعني لا
تخشى ان تكون هذه التفاصيل ستنسف مره اخرى
المسار الانتقالي الممتد لعامين لانه كان
هناك مسار مشابه سابقا
نعم هذا تحدي اساسي في هذه العمليه
السياسيه لان ما سيتم توقيعه غدا هو
اتفاقا ايطاليا بالتالي لن يكون هنالك
حكومه او نقاش حول شكل
اسماء بالنسبه للحكومه لان
فقط سيتم الاتفاق على معايير رئيس الوزراء
معايير من سيشغلوا المناطق وهذا سيستغرق
وقت ايضا قضيه شائكه مثل قضيه العداله همم
والان تم توسيع مفهوم العداله بحيث لا
يشمل الذين فقط سقطوا او يرتقت ارواحهم في
خلال التظاهرات الاخيره ولكن مفهوم
العداله بشكل جديد ااه يشمل قضايا اا
عميقه وحساسه وربما تستغرق وقت لان غدايا
مثل السلال العداله في دارفور العداله في
الشرق في جبال النوبه غير قضيه مثل اصلاح
القطاع الامني صحيح وهو الفيل داخل الغرفه
كيف يصل الجميع الى جداول زمنيه تحدد
عمليه دمج الجيشين مع بعضهم البعض قضايا
مثل علاقه المؤسسه العسكريه بالحياه
السياسيه الاتفاق على شكل المجلس التشريعي
وعضويته وكيف يتكون هذا سيستغرق شهور في
تقدير البسيط صحيح ان القائمين على هذا
الامر يقولون انهم في خلال شهر همم يناير
همم
الايطالي او في هذا المسار الجديد خاصه
كما تفضلت انه المسار يمتد لعامين فيه
مؤشرات ايجابيه صحيحه هناك بعض القضايا
التي ما تزال ربما تترك للنقاش خلال هذا
المسار ولكن من
استمرار او ال ال يعني تنفيذ اجنده هذا
الاتفاق بين هذه القوى
اا من الواضح ان الاليه الثلاثيه همم هي
التي ستكون همم ستوقع وهي التي سترتد
الحوار من ناحيه الضامنين اعتقد ان
الرباعيه الدوليه التي تضم الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا والامارات والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه بالضروره وهؤلاء هم
الذين هم الاتحاد الاوروبي وغيرهم الذين
سيحضرون يمكن ان يكونوا اا ضامنين همم
لهذا الاتفاق لكن الذي سيضمن اكثر اا هو
الشارع همم السوداني فاذا شارع السوداني
خرج همم وقال ان همم الذي حدث هو اا تطور
مهم ويدعمه هذا هو الدعم همم الضمان
الحقيقيه اما اذا رفده همم الشارع
السوداني وتصاعدت همم التظاهرات همم لم
يجد فتيلا اي كوه اخرى ان تقدم ضمانات
لذلك انا في تقدير شخص اعتقد من الافضل
عليك هذه القوى السياسيه ان تتجه مباشره
لفصل المسار التنفيذي من المسار السياسي
بمعنى ان يتم اختيار رئيس وزراء من من هذه
القوه السياسيه ليقوم بتشكيل حكومه لان
هذه القضايا الاربعه المؤجله قضايا شائكه
وكانت مسار نقاش في طوال تاريخ السودان
السياسي وعلى اقل تقدير في الفتره الاخيره
اربعه اشهر لنصل للاتفاق الاول بعد سقوط
البشير استغرقنا حوالي عام كامل لنصل
لقضايا السلام الان الوضعي سيكون همم
يحتاج همم اكثر من نوايا صحيح اشكركم شكرا
جزيلا عمار عوض انتم الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي مباشره من الخرطوم
تسويه تحكم عليها بالفشل لانه ذات المشكله
اللي كانت موجوده في خمسه اشهر طب هتتكرر
ممكن نصحى في اي يوم نصحى الصباح نلقى انه
نفس البيان بتاع 25 اكتوبر تكرر ثاني
وثالث ورابع لانه هم موجودين على قياده
همم الجيش على قياده الدعم السريع افتكر
انه فرص نياحه الشارع باكد انه ما هتكون
فيها فرص نجاح تفتكر انه التسويه تاسيس لي
الحكم مدني النسبه للتجارب الكثيره اللي
حصلت يعني ما بين المدنيين والعسكريين ما
مين نجحنا لانه لا انت ما بتقرب المدرب
[موسيقى]
في تونس قررت الغرفه النقابيه للمؤسسات
الصيدليه الموزعه للادويه بالجمله ايقافه
تزويد الصيدليات بالادويه انطلاقا من يوم
غد الاثنين الى حين ايجاد حلول فعليه
لانقاذ القطاع وضمان توزيع الادويه في
البلاد والحفاظ على حق المريض في الدواء
الاحد هو يوم عطله في تونس تتوقفوا بموجبه
جل الانشطه في البلاد الصيدليات بدورها
تخضع لهذه القاعده ويخلق معظمها ابوابه
لكن هذه المره قد يتواصلوا هذا الاغلاق
الى اجل غير مسمى بسبب قرار موزعي الادويه
بالجمله ايقافه تزويد الصيدليات بالادويه
هذا الاعفاء همم يعطي لهم من سنه 2016
وزاره الماليه رفضت اعطى احد الوفاء مما
قد يسبب لهم حجز في السيوله الماليه قد
يقدر 50% من هذا القطاع الى الافلاس
نقابته موزعي الادويه بالجمله تؤكد ان
قرارها يعود الى عدم التوصل الى حل وعدم
تجديد شهاده خصم من المورد للمؤسسات
الموزعه للادويه بالجمله على ما بيعات
الادويه لسنه 22
ونظرا للارتفاع المتواصل الى الاعباء
الماليه لهذه المؤسسات ما يتسبب في ازمه
خانقه وضعيه تضرر معها نشاط الصيادله
واشتكى منها المواطن ضرر في النشاط فما
ضرار في همم
فريطم بتاع التزاوج ويخلينا نخموف
النهارين الجايين زيد القدام نقرا حسبنا
انت وهو مش من بصوا الوفر والادويه
المطلوبه والكل
في نقص في المواد الغذائيه
الدوله
النشاط
التي تحجب غابه مشاكل القطاع السياحيه
والتي تنطلق من اهتراء البنيه التحتيه
الصحيه ولا تتوقف عند تدني الخدمات الصحيه
ونقص الادويه ما يجعل جل المرضى يكافحون
بلا سلاح ضد الامراض وخاصه الخطيره
والمزمنه منها وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
[موسيقى]
حذر وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن حكومه نتنياهو المقبله في اسرائيل
من اقامه مستوطنه جديده وتعاهد بمعارضه
المستوطنات والضم في الضفه الغربيه واكد
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انه واشنطن
ستواصلوا معارضتها الصريحه لاي اعمال تقود
افاق حال الدوله تين بما فيها التوسع
الاستضامي وتغيير الوضع التاريخي الحالي
للاماكن المقدسه والتحريض على العنف
[موسيقى]
شين مشاهدينا بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
نتابع بركان اكبر بركان نشط في العالم
يوصل ثورانه والصور التي تشاهدون هي الصور
مباشره من البركان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام من جديد اذا
نذهب الى هذه الصور المباشره مشاهدينا
لاستمرار ثوران بركان اكبر بركان نشط في
العالم هذا المكان الذي يقع فيها واي
والذي بدا ثورانه هذا الاسبوع لاول مره
منذ عام
هذه الحمم كذلك من هذا البركان الذي بدا
هذا الثوران اذا مشاهدينا بعد اعلان وكاله
اداره الطوارئ انه لا توجد مؤشرات على ان
هذه الحمم البركانيه التي تشاهدون ستهدد
المناطق الماهوله بالسكان بدا العشرات
يتوافدون يوميا بالقرب من القمه وقالت
السلطات ان تدفقات الحمم البركانيه من لون
اللواء بدات
وتنتشر
وذكر مركز البراكين في هوايه تابع لهيئه
المسح الجيولوجيه الامريكيه في احدث نشره
عن هذا البركان ان تدفق الحنه من
البركانيه الرئيسيه يتحرك 40 مترا في
الساعه واضاف انه مازال يرصد نشاطا
زلزاليا في المنطقه مما يعني ان الحمى ما
زالت تتدفق الى الشقوق ومن المرجح ان
يستمر النشاط طالما اننا نرى هذه الاشاره
ونشاهد هذه الصوره يعني تدفق الحمام ويقع
مولنا اللي هو مشاهدينا على ارتفاع
4.169 متر فوق المحيط الهادي وهو جزء من
سلسله من البراكين التي شكلت جزر هاواي
وكان اخر ثوران له في مارس وابريل عام
والى مونديال كاس العالم الصفاء الذهنيه
ساهم بتاهل فرق والقضايا السياسيه ساهمت
بخروج اخرى هو امراه مدرب ارسنال السابق
ارسن بنجر قائلا ان المنتخبات التي تاهلت
بدون مشاكل كانت الافضل استعدادا ذهنيا
ولم تشتت انتباهها بالقضايا السياسيه وفي
اشاره الى خروج المانيا وبلجيكا والدنمارك
المفاجئ الى البطوله اكد ان المنتخبات
التي ركزت على كره القدم بدات بشكل جيد
مثل البرازيل وفرنسا وانجلترا وتاهلت لدور
ال 16 بسهوله
[موسيقى]
تجمع عدد من محبي فريق كره القدم
البرازيليه سانتوس امام مستشفى البرت
اينشتاين في مدينه ساو باولو للدعاء
اللاعب لاعب كره القدم الاسطوره بيليه وقد
تم نقل اديسون دو نصيب
للمستشفى بسبب تعقيدات سرطان على مستوى
الجهاز الهضمي حيث لم يعد جسمه يتقبل
العلاج الكيماوي وفي اخر تصريح صادر عنها
يوم السبت قال انا قوي وعندي الكثير من
الامل
[موسيقى]
توقف مع هذا العاجل منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه تقول ان النظام الايراني اعدم
اكثر من 500 شخص في عام 2022 قبل اكثر من
شهر بقليل اصبح تويتر
لم يجب اسم تويتر عن عناوين الاخبار ويبدو
ان التصرفات مصر
الازرق
الجماعيه من قبل مشاهير ومتابعين على نطاق
واسع مع ظهوره
العنصريه واوضح ان ماسك كان اصدر عفوا
واسعا عن معظم الحسابات المحظوره
افكارا العنصريه على الموقع
ملكيه تويتر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سوريا الاعلاميه المصريه الراحل مفيد فوزي
الثرى بعد وصوله الى كنيسه المرعشلي بحي
الزمالك في العاصمه المصريه القاهره
وتوفي فوزي عن عمر نهز 89 عاما بعد رحله
معاناه مع المرضى وحرص عدد من الصحفيين
والفنانين المصريين على حضوره جنازه
الاعلامي المصري
مشاهدينا نهايه اخبار الساعه لهذه الليله
شكرا لكم على المتابعه المزيد دائما يبقى
العربيه على صفحتنا على مواقع التواصل الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]